[Musica]
che belle canzoni di martin garris i
ragazzi aspettino di avessero video sono
affari già oggi siamo tornati su motori
dreams se non conoscete sui motori deans
non meritate di vivere questo era un
videogioco che avevo giocato tipo
quattro anni fa e ogni tanto mi battono
i films e voglia di giocare a sta roba
dispiace ragazzi che cosa consiste il
suo gioco anche perché non ho mai capito
protetto di spiegarlo è lo stesso io
sono più lo è l'obiettivo è quello di
buttarsi fuori dal ring cioè quello che
rimane in piedi per ultimo tipo il
marrone in questo caso ha vinto nè se
poi bisogna mai riscontrato l'ha
partorito einstein questo questo video
games infatti proprio la avvenuta dalla
sua mente ragazzo col passare del tempo
non l'ho più fatto per un motivo
effettivamente una sauber che ha
estratto tutto motivo mi sono dimesso
giocare a roma per ogni tanto mi parlò
di chili
perché ti chiamo fratè private la porta
talmente potente che lasciato il gioco
ben gioco dell'anno ragazzi social punto
s.mo non mi chiedete che cosa diavolo e
non lo voglio sapere
già mi chiamasse ricordato che devi dire
basta al culo cup capiamoci yo yo
italiano noi italiani forti a calcio
tedesco crucco schifoso bastardo siamo
gli azzurri noi non posso permettermi di
non segnare se segno l'italia vince il
mondiale ha fatto a madre toppa ma come
ti permetti testa di culo se non è
quello e farlo però l'arbitro non ha
visto niente anche perché non c'è
l'arbitro
arbitrerà il marrone da dall'alcolismo
nel video precedente ma mai così mai
così così zio mai così 4 tempo per
segnare non vedranno vendola parla
telecamera non vedova e senza neanche
vedere la palla signori di morire jacket
è stata in bocca gli ha dato dunque
ragazzi questo è un gioco di
intelligenza e io non so come mai smesso
di giocarci
smettete di fare queste cose scene
grazie ai ragazzi prima questa cos'è sta
roba questo se la torchi in teoria
dovrebbe fare delle robe simpatiche io
non l'ho toccherò e che è vincitore di
questa partita non lo sapremo mai perché
è stato appena impanato da una tegola
gigante marghe che a cosa dobbiamo fare
dobbiamo buttarci giù ma buttatevi oi
jolo attento averla tetto verde ecco le
persone a botta incredibile io sono
caduto insomma come amiche ho fatto ma
da akai al reattore nucleare ma che
razza livello è questo spiega che cosa
dovrebbe arca vacca dobbiamo toccare
qualcosa in mezzo credo che ormai
sbattono prima sul palo
è infatti lo toccate per cortesia così
capisco cos'è fatelo voi che io non c'ho
voglia di morire
faccio io che sono ci mettete 12 anni ci
sono ragazze do cosa serve questa roba
che non ho capito mi sono pagato
fortissimo dove miglia sto andando al
mio tiro
era un petardo gigante con sanno la roba
lì è stato molto figo però non me lo
aspettavo mai potreste andare voi per
una volta sempre io devo fare la cavia
però non mi copro ma non mi tocca ma che
cazzo vuoi borja schifosa maledetto sì
però ragazzi non potete fare ste orge
mentre non ci sono basta a limonare il
palo tanti problemi quest'uomo chiamata
occhio occhio marrone occhio nome a
barone la sega occhio io vengano a me io
dico che ho agli a un genio proprio di
genius posso fare perché a me l'occhio
occhio schiva schiva non so se scrivendo
hanno schivato porca era schifosa no
dovrei non sono di aiuto non solo
piaciuto non lo scriva così facendo il
signor mi stai aspettando l'aria grazie
molto gentile la telecamera fa sempre il
suo sporco lavoro in questo gioco grazie
a dio siamo arrivati alla fine grazie a
dio arrivo anch'io era già fermi tutti
ho buttato giù il bianco non so cosa
stai facendo verde yoga non sto toccando
niente fa da solo c'è per farvi capire
quanto non ha senso
ragazzi siamo resi conto di essere
piccoli ce l'ha messa a giocare nella
sabbia inizio io passami la valente la
paletta non la bomba porcava saputi
morti
sembra una storia d'amore migliore di
twilight per mito tv proverei del senso
a sopravvivere per aiutarti in mezzo
subito in mezzo subito
ad angelo arma che palle per una volta
che sopravvivo io mamma la testata
indietro cosa vuoi fare livello per
gioire della mia presenza
capisco è un sentimento che ti viene dal
cuore
pensa per quanto sono innamorato di te
lo spaccato oppure il terreno lo sa il
nostro amore che era un pélé barriere di
si sfalda me lo ricordo ragazzi devo
fare questa e sparta con un tipo non mi
chiedo se cado io se cade chi altro
questa è tua madre non cadrò io non
cadrò io so già melo caduto in un
ricordo gli sta bene è la madonna cos'è
a c'è un pavimento di sorta ma ho visto
accado anch'io sto tentando di
suicidarmi ma come potete vedere il sto
trovando difficoltà nel farlo e sono
sono vent'anni che gioca videogiochi
purtroppo non ho queste capacità ancora
sviluppate però mi ci mettono impegno e
prometto che uno era per farlo mi
chiesero beccarino se non pecca quanto
li devo se lo beccava passavo il resto
il video a ridere ragazzi io verso
estremi non riesco a fare qualcosa di de
cecco 6 sta roba
dobbiamo bravo marrone hai dato prova di
te oggi sei stato molto più bravo del
solito tra l'altro marrone fuori dalle
balle subito professore una specie di
ponte occhio arriva a mantova ma quanto
è difficile il suo livello
sono ancora vivo il verde è diventata
una frittella mi saprà nel dubbio io
sono ancora vivo se magari riuscissi ad
alzarmi sarebbe anche bravo verde sei
così facendo cosa fa quello cosa faccio
io
siamo tutti i contagiati qual è il
problema
ragazzi mi sa che il verde l'abbiamo
perso però va bene così anche perché
effettivamente non è che ci siano mai
stati gli altri secondo voi ragazzi
questo video classificato come family
friendly da youtube sono solo spintoni e
cadute da 200 metri di altezza con spine
però secondo me no ecco quello di prima
la spal che erano fermi tutti marrone
non mi tocca t'ammazzo non mi toccare
già difficile sopravvivere ti prego
fatica site pro nota vai via schifoso
pervertito maledizione ovviamente il
bianco il verde non ha capito la che
parte dovevano andare rimangono a
ingrossarsi sul bordo di lasciamo
perdere ce la fai marrone buttati giù al
benfici dati fa una cosa di utile
bravo tesoro qualcuno mi spiega
l'utilità di questi livelli ragazzi
ancora non l'ho capito
occhio al vado perché dovete prendere il
pane in faccia o il problema fede un
attimo dalla sabbia non è che la salta
sempre in aria io l'ho chiamata che l'ho
visto è saltata in aria
no ecco farghal accademica che si stava
spegnendo il sogno per meno male minore
che sono saltato si sa dove sono finito
no non si è capito del soffitto però
babbei o lo posso rifarlo eccomi mica
un'ora dopo è zio a zia zia panaraba
però stata lì dietro state migliaccio
vedere che succede
porca vacca me ma io non ce l'ho
sopravanzata all'indietro forte
[Musica]
porca la vacca incrostata è la quale
avevo dubbi
ma che cosa starà mica è devo andare
avanti sperando di non cadere io per
primo occhio e il vincitore vincitore si
capisce giocava in pure in casa perché
il pavimento e del tuo colore maledetto
maghetta ho già capito regaleremo
schiacciati brutalmente lo sapete
spero che io io io vado sua presenza più
cavalco sono i piedi o mio giro erano
dei veri pd per un secondo verso non
riesce a camminare per riesce a saltare
cosi movimento rimanere in piedi ma non
capisco proprio mi spiega cos'è sta roba
che non è un campo minato occhio ragazzi
come dai andate voi occhi occhio a chi
occhio a sinistra sinistra sinistra ma
che gliela fa pensavo molto peggio
potevate impegnarmi un po di più a
mettere qualcosa di fottutamente
esplosivo oltre che dei pegni che escono
fuori dal pavimento vale ragazzi dire
che possono chiudere qui se i suoi dati
su motori dreams è stato bellissimo
rigiocarci anche perché mi mancava un
saudita di quel periodo in cui sono con
i films c'è da giocare roba vecchia e
mai ho fatto certamente sì sei contento
anche tu caro zio dei ragazzi spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto io concludo
quale episodio anche perché credo che
questo sia stato in totale è uno dei più
bei giochi che abbiamo giocato sul mio
canale senza scherzare è veramente è
stato uno dei più esilaranti almeno ai
tempi poi non so adesso magari è uscita
la mente tanta roba negli ultimi anni
che forse è stato decisamente battuto ma
rimane uno dei giochi più belli che
abbia mai potuto pagare questo
sicuramente però a furia di farlo mi
sono anche tartassati maroni e qualcuno
potrebbe anche capirmi quindi ragazzoni
spero che visto che sia piaciuto cose
al momento mi piace anche vari social
che convenire dotato nella scrittura se
non si resiste bene ci vediamo al
prossimo video sono un sadico maledetto
beh ragazzi
[Musica]